I'd like to start by telling you the
story of two women born early in the
20th
century they lived on different coasts
they had different religious backgrounds
and they were in different stages of
life when each experienced an unwanted
pregnancy Sally was newly married at the
start of the Great Depression she and
her husband decided they couldn't afford
to start a family yet but abortion was
illegal in New York City and so she
traveled to Puerto Rico to get an
illegal abortion Dorothy had recently
graduated from high school when she
became pregnant by a much older golf
instructor her conservative parents
shunned her and she had to go away to a
Salvation Army home for unwed mothers
where she gave birth and placed the
child for
adoption these women were my
grandmothers and they're part of the
reason I became a demographer and
professor studying the causes and
consequences of unintended
pregnancy for years people have alleged
that abortion harms women the idea that
abortion causes mental health harm in
particular has been used to justify laws
that ban abortion or try and dissuade
people from choosing it this came to a
head in 2007 when Supreme Court Justice
Anthony Kennedy allowed restrictions on
abortion to stand because as he said
while we find no reliable data to
measure the phenomenon it seems
unexceptionable to conclude that some
women come to regret their choice to
abort the infant life they once created
and sustained severe depression and loss
of esteem can
follow no reliable data those are words
a demographer lives
for we began data collection the very
next year
to study the outcomes for people who get
abortions you need a comparison group
ideally people who want an abortion and
can't get them because they would be an
exactly the same circumstances but one
group gets the abortion and the other
group
doesn't my research team at the
University of California San Francisco
went to 30 abortion facilities across
the country each one selected because it
was distant enough from other clinics
that if someone were too far along in
pregnancy for that clinic there was very
few other places they could go at each
site we focused on recruiting two groups
of people women who were just under the
limit and got their abortions and women
who showed up a little bit too late in
pregnancy and were turned
away I called it the turnaway study and
the study design was a success in
analyzing the data we see those two
groups were the same at the start women
who received and women who were denied
abortions had similar mental health
physical health and socioeconomic
well-being at the time they sought an
abortion we followed almost a thousand
women calling them every 6 months for 5
years using scientifically validated
questions to measure their physical
health their Mental Health and their
family's well-being and we can see that
although they started the same those two
groups their lives diverged in ways that
could be directly attributed to whether
they got their abortion or were turned
away and it didn't work out the way that
Kennedy had un exceptiona
concluded in fact we found no mental
health harm from abortion instead we saw
higher anxiety lower self-esteem lower
life satisfaction for the people who
were denied the
abortion but this difference didn't last
over time the two groups looked the same
not because both groups were doing
poorly in terms of mental health in fact
symptoms of depression and anxiety
improved for both groups over time but
the two groups diverged in other
important
ways we find worse physical health for
women who carried the pregnancy to term
and gave birth consistent with the vast
medical literature we see that
childbirth is associated with greater
risks and abortion including Hemorrhage
eclampsia and even
death and the differences in physical
health don't end at the time of
childbirth for years later we saw higher
chronic pain more hypertension and
overall worse physical health for women
who were denied the abort abortion and
gave birth we also find large
socioeconomic differences where women
who are denied abortions face more
hardships than women who receive
abortions we find an increase in public
assistance but it's not enough to make
up for a loss of full-time
employment women often raising children
alone end up falling below the federal
poverty level working with economists I
was able to show that those who received
and those who were denied abortions were
similar economically for years before
the year of The Unwanted pregnancy but
for years after we see more debt lower
credit scores and a greater chance of
eviction and bankruptcy for people who
were turned
away and one other area of difference
I'll mention we see differences in the
chance that women set and Achieve
aspirational plans for their future this
includes things like breaking ties with
abusive Partners finding high quality
romantic
relationships getting Advanced
educational
degrees financially supporting their
older children and even differences in
the chance of having an intended
pregnancy later the results of my study
consistently show that when there is a
difference those who were able to get
their wanted abortion did better than
those who
weren't this may come as a surprise to
people who don't think about why women
get abortions women often give many
reasons housing and financial
circumstances their relationship with
the man involved in the pregnancy their
need to take care of existing children
more than half of those seeking
abortions nationally are already
parenting at least one child all of the
areas women were concerned about
finances children relationships life
aspirations were the areas in which we
see
differences in the experiences of those
denied abortions we see all their
concerns playing out exactly as they
anticipated when they were deciding
whether to have an abortion their
concerns were
Justified over the 5 years we followed
them we see that over 95% of those who
Reed their abortion said it was the
right decision for
them very few of those people who gave
birth decided to place the child for
adoption less than 10% so there's
another example of a Supreme Court
Justice making an assumption that turned
out to be wrong may remember Amy Coney
Barrett in deliberating on ending 50
years of abortion rights in our country
suggested that women could drop their
babies off at fire
stations
we find that once people have taken the
risk and made the Monumental sacrifice
of giving birth to a child most people
decide to parent that child adoption is
not an easy choice and in fact the women
who placed children for adoption were
the most likely to say that they were
having difficulty coping with their
experience it's not news to me that some
people think abort is wrong but when
someone's in the circumstance where they
are pregnant and they cannot support a
child and take care of their existing
children or make a decent life for thems
they're trying to make a decision that
is right for their life and their
family as the abortion provider Dr
George tiller used to say before his
murder in 2009 trust
women
[Applause]
access to Safe legal abortion is
important for all of us unintended
pregnancy is very common in my family in
all of our families across our country
in red States and blue States and across
the globe I've worked with Scientists in
Tunisia Colombia South Africa Bangladesh
and Nepal to study the experiences of
people who are pregnant when they aren't
ready and we see these same concerns
about wanting to have children under the
right
circumstances access to abortion is
universally fundamentally important to
the well-being of
[Applause]
families the overwhelming International
trend is towards liberalizing abortion
laws and not like the United States of
imposing new restrictions until the
United States rejoins the rest of the
world there is a lot we can do to
support pregnant people whether they do
or do not want to carry that pregnancy
to term we need much more generous and
less punitive supports for low-income
families like income supports extended
periods of Health Care coverage child
care and parental leave so nobody
decides to end and otherwise want Ed
pregnancy for economic reasons alone but
when someone's in the position where
they don't have the circumstances where
they want to raise a child and they want
to end their pregnancy they need the
information and resources to do so
safely since the 2022 Supreme Court Do's
decision that overturned row and ended
Federal protections for abortion rights
we see that people who are experiencing
an unwanted pregnancy are determined
people have strong motivation because
they understand the consequences of
carrying an unwanted pregnancy to
term people who have the resources to
circumvent their state law by traveling
or ordering medication abortion pills
online
do now with large swaths of the Southern
United States and Midwest without a
single legal abortion clinic women who
can travel hundreds of miles to get an
abortion out of state people without the
emotional and financial and social
resources to travel that includes Miners
and immigrants and people whose travel
is restricted because of their own
health or the law will experience all
the hardships we've documented in the
turnaway
study the importance of control over
childbearing is also shown in the
stories of my
grandmothers my father's mother Sally
got her abortion in Puerto Rico and went
on with her life which included having
three children later when her financial
footing was more secure she was warm and
funny and a wonderful
mom
my my other grandmother who gave birth
she experienced severe complications
from child birth both physical and
emotional after placing my mother for
adoption struggled to find strong
romantic relationships and she never did
get to have more children although she
desperately wanted to my mother found
her when I was 12 and she and I became
very close she was my nearest relative
when I went off to college at UC
Berkeley and she even came to visit me
when I was in graduate school at
Princeton and I was the one by by her
side holding her hand when she died many
years
later what I think about her experience
is that her life took a detour when she
got pregnant as a teenager and she never
found a way to get back on the track she
wanted the experiences of my
grandmothers are consistent with the
turnaway study and also show us what to
expect in this post job world what we
know is that being able to make one's
own decision about childbearing without
government interference is crucial for
the economic well-being of families and
allows people to pursue personal and
educational goals including having
wanted children
later access to abortion is about
control over one's body life and Destiny
thank
[Applause]
you